what I want to do in this video is
differentiate between the ideas of
nucleophilicity nucleo
Felicity or how strong fearless city or
how strong of a nucleophile something is
and basicity and basicity and these the
difference is on one level kind of
subtle but it's actually a very big
difference and I'll show you why it's
kind of confusing the first time you
learn it when we studied sn2 reactions
you have a nucleophile that has an extra
electron right here it has a negative
charge and maybe you have a methyl
carbon maybe you have a methyl carbon
let me draw it let me draw it maybe you
have a hydrogen coming out you have a
hydrogen behind it you have a hydrogen
up top and then you have a leaving group
you have a leaving group right over
there and in an sn2 reaction the
nucleophile will give this electron to
the carbon the carbon has a partial
positive charge let me draw that partial
positive charge the leaving group has a
partial negative charge because it tends
to be or it will be more electronegative
and so this electron is given to this
carbon right when the carbon gets that
are simultaneously with it this
electronegative leading group is able to
take is able to completely take this
electron away from the carbon and then
after you are done it looks like this we
have our methyl carbon so the hydrogen
in the back hydrogen in the front
hydrogen on top the leaving group has
left leaving group has left it had this
electron right there but now it also
took that magenta electron it took that
magenta electron so it now has a
negative charge and the nucleophile the
nucleophile has given has given this
electron right over here and so now it
is bonded to the carbon now the whole
reason I did this is because okay this
is acting as a nucleophile it loves
nucleus is it's giving away its extra
electron but it is also acting as a
lewis base
it is also acting as a lewis base and is
a bit of a refresher a lewis base which
is really the most general or i guess it
covers the the most examples of what it
means to be a base it lewis base means
that you are an electron donor electron
donor and that's exactly what's
happening here this nucleophile is
donating an electron to the carbon so
it's acting as a lewis base so the first
time you see that you're like well why
did chemists even go through the pain of
defining something like a nucleophile
why don't they just call it a base why
are there two different concepts of
nucleophilicity and basicity and the
difference is is that nucleophilicity is
a kinetic concept it is kinetic which
means how good is it at reacting how
fast is it reacting how little extra
energy does it need to react so
something has good nucleophilicity it is
good at reacting good at reacting it
tells you it doesn't tell you anything
about how stable or unstable the
reactants before and after are just
tells you they're good at reacting with
each other
basicity basicity is a thermodynamic
concept thermo dynamic it's telling you
how stable are the reactants or the
products so it tells you it tells you
how badly how badly something would like
to react something would would like to
react for example we saw the kitten
situation of fluorine we saw the let's
let's think about this we saw the
exaggeration we actually I say fluoride
so fluoride looks like this seven
valence electrons for fluorine and then
you have it swiped one extra electron
away you get fluoride so floor ride is
reasonably basic it is more basic than
iodide so this is more basic than iodide
more basic
then then iodide but in a protic
solution put in let me write it here but
less less nucleophilic less nucleophilic
in parodic in parodic solution in a
protic solution once again has hydrogen
protons around and the reason why this
is is fluoride it wants to bond with
let's say a carbon or something else
more badly or maybe even a hydrogen
proton it wants to bond with it more
badly than an iodide anion and if it did
it actually will be a stronger bond than
the iodide and anion will form that the
fluoride anion is actually less stable
in this form then the iodide is if you
were really able to get a pro to proton
or give its electron away it will be
happier but it's less nucleophilic it's
less good at reacting in a product
solution and the whole reason it's less
nucleophilic is because there are other
things that are keeping from reacting
and we saw on the video on what makes a
good nucleophile then in the case of
fluoride it's because it forms hydrogen
it's a very small atom actually say a
very small ion and so it forms so it's
very closely held the electron clouds
very is it's very tight and so what it
allows is the hydrogen's from the water
to form a very tight shell a very tight
shell around these all have partial
positive charges so they are attracted
to the negative anion and so they form a
very tight shell kind of protecting the
fluoride anion which makes it harder for
the harder for it to react in a protic
solution so doesn't react as well
doesn't react as well if it was able to
react it actually will form a stronger
bond then the iodide anion so that's the
big difference and just so we see the
difference in trends so basicity it does
not matter what your actual solvent is
it is a thermodynamic property of the
molecule or the
or the anion so if you looked at just
pure basicity basicity the strongest
base you see and I'll just write
hydroxide here it's normally something
like sodium hydroxide or potassium
hydroxide but when you dissolve it in
say something like water they the sodium
and the hydroxide separate and it's
really the hydroxide that is acting as a
base something that wants to donate
electrons so hydroxide is a much
stronger base than fluoride which is a
stronger base than chloride which is a
stronger base than bromide which is a
stronger base which is a stronger base
than iodide now if you were to look at
if you were to look at nucleophilicity
just to see the difference nucleo
félicité we saw that there actually
matters what's the solvent because the
solvent will affect how good something
is at reacting so nucleophilicity either
is a difference between a protic solvent
and an a protic solvent a protic solvent
in a protic solvent the most nucleophile
the thing that has the best
nucleophilicity is actually iodide
because it's not hindered by these
hydrogen bonds as much it doesn't have a
tight shell has this big molecular cloud
and some people think it also has kind
of a softness it has this polarizability
where that cloud can be pulled towards
the carbon and do what it needs to do so
in this case iodide is is a better
nucleophile let me just say then
hydroxide which is a better nucleophile
then fluoride now in an a protic
solution where all of a sudden where all
of a sudden the the the interactions
with the solvent are not going to be as
significant then things change in this
situation basicity matters so in an a
predict in an a product solution
basicity basicity and and
nucleophilicity nucleophilicity
correlate and i'll put I'll put out put
a and asterisks and asterisks here
because there's also one other aspect of
new
we'll see - I haven't talked about yet
but I'll talk about it in a second but
in this type of a situation hydroxide
hydroxide will be better at reacting
than floor fluoride which will be better
at reacting then iodide and the whole
reason why in both situations in both
situations hydroxide hydroxide is I mean
even in even weather it can interact
with the solvent it's still a pretty
good nucleophile because if you think
about hydroxide if you think about
hydroxide I have to think about this a
lot it has an extra electron right if
you think about it it's you could
imagine it's water that took away let me
draw it this way you can imagine it's
it's water that where proton left or
where an electron was taken from a
proton so normally you have two pairs
and now you have a third pair right here
this oxygen has 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 valence
electrons one more than neutral oxygen
so it has a negative charge
so it already has an extra it already
has an extra electron that gives us
negative charge but oxygen is also more
electronegative than hydrogen so it's
also able to get this guy involved a
little bit it's also able to get this
guy involved a little bit anyway so it's
very very it's a very basic very basic
molecule so even when it might be
interfered a little bit by a protic
environment like water it's still a
better nucleophile it's still a better
nucleophile than something like fluoride
if you take the solvent out of the
picture it's a super strong base and so
it's also going to be a very very good
nucleophile now the last aspect of
nucleophilicity remember nucleophilicity
is how good something reacts now let's
imagine let's imagine we have something
here so we have we have two two
molecules two hydroxide molecules right
two hydroxide molecules and let's say
that this one is let's just say this one
is just a straight up this is just a
straight-up hydroxide and let's say this
one over here has all sorts of things
off of it let's say it's you know it
just has this big chain of stuff it just
has this big chain of stuff I don't know
which one now if you were to look at
these two molecules if you were to try
to guess which one is going to be a
better
clea file you should just remember
nucleophilicity is how good something
reacts how good is it getting in there
and and making a reaction happen now
this thing has this big molecule all
around it it might actually make it very
hard if you go back to this circumstance
up here it might be make it very hard
for it to get in there we've talked
about steric hindrance from the point of
view of the carbon but we haven't really
talked about it from the point of view
of the nucleophile in this nucleophile
right here it might be hard it might be
hard for this extra electron right here
for this electra extra electron right
there to actually get to the target
nucleus it will be hindered while in
this situation it will be much easier
even though even though the group that's
reacting this oxygen would that has a
negative charge this extra electron is
on some level fairly fairly equivalent
but this one right here will be much
more it looks a much smaller molecule
it'll be less hindered easier to get in
so this will be a better nucleophile
better nucleophile and that's what I
wanted to make that's why I did I wanted
to I did want to make the same state the
strong statement that an a protic
solution basicity and nucleophilicity
are completely correlated because
nucleophilicity still has that other
element of you know how hindered is it
is it in an environment where or is it
part of a molecule that will keep it
from reacting even though it might be a
very strong base if it actually forms a
bond it'll be very strong so the big
thing to remember is that they're just
two fundamentally different concepts and
that's why they're two different terms
for them nucleophilicity how good is it
at reacting saying nothing about how
good the resulting bond is basicity is
how good is the bond how badly does it
want to react but it doesn't say how
good is it at reacting itself